he's gonna lose  yeah I mean we don't I don't see it  there is no way you're gonna defend this  position might as well resign he's  carrying it out a bit but okay to bring  in the king well actually rookie it will  be it uh 97.95 that's how he's yeah but  look dates yeah  and  he resigns  wow what a stunner  Timmy have beats the world champion from  a nothing position  and catches him  well it was more than nothing it was if  if someone and only black and hard  camera was done to one and a half  minutes versus 11 of Magnus so I believe  that magnus's problem was that yeah he  got careless yeah he thought like okay I  can do whatever I want yeah  it could just don't hang a piece  so it's wide open again Magnus Carlson